The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So hopefully by the
end of the class, we will show
you a histogram for the quiz.
We are very happy.
You guys did really well, so
we feel like, actually, you
learned something in the quiz,
so it makes us happy.
We're hoping to have
the histogram ready
by now, but we don't.
By end of the class, hopefully
we take a break in a middle,
and go through rest of that.
So we are going a little bit off
from regular programming.
If you look at the class
schedule, we are going to have
a guest lecture today, but I am
the guest lecture, I guess.
So I'm going to talk about what
compilers can and cannot
do because, as you went on last
couple of projects, you
tried hard to do weird things
out of the compiler, create
different piece of code,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
programs.
And so I'm going to kind of,
first, walk through some stuff
that is very practical,
what the current
GCC do or don't do.
OK, so we'll go through some
stuff, which is interesting,
and then I'm going to--
let's get the outline first.
OK, this doesn't work.
OK.
Then we will talk a little more
about where the normal
optimizations happen, what are
all the possibilities, just
very quickly, to give
you a feel.
It's not all static
type compilation.
And then go through
two things.
One is data-flow analysis
and optimization.
That's a big part what
compilers does.
And then also instructions
scheduling.
Instruction scheduling might
not be that important on a
superscalar.
but it's always good to know
what it does because there are
some cases where you had to
do it in the compiler the
hardware cannot do, so we'll
look at some of those cases.
So the first thing that we found
a lot of you guys did is
you try to inline a lot of code
in your projects, and in
fact, one way to do that
is have you do a macro.
A macro basically make sure that
definitely get in line,
but macros are ugly.
There are many things you can't
really do with a macro.
The other thing is, we can
actually do simple max
calculation using function.
OK, starting function defined.
And the first one is
calling this one.
Second one is calling
this one.
So what do you think this
is going to do?
How many people think that the
code produced between this and
this going to be drastically
different?
Code produced for this function
versus this function
going to be drastically
different?
Real different.
For some people,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
going to be different.
OK, why do you think
it's different?
GUEST SPEAKER: So the second
function calls the first
function, and the first
[INAUDIBLE]
calls the second one.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So since you have the
first one calling max1,
which is a macro, the compiler
just copied [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
out of there.
Whereas the second one--
it will try to actually
optimize the--
Won't it try to optimize what
is inside un64 [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So what he thinks
is that is just
going to get copied.
This will be still a function
call, try and do some
optimizing.
In fact, what it will do is, the
first function is going to
get inline.
Something interesting here, what
you see is even though
there's a condition here,
there's no branch.
They have the same old
instruction that basically can
be used to do a conditional
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So instead of having a branch
and having a pipeline
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], this managed
to convert this into nice,
direct call.
The interesting thing is the
second one is also identical,
so what it did was it said, hi,
I know this function, I
can inline.
It got inline automatically.
You didn't tell you to do, the
compiler actually inlined it
for you, and then did all the
things that are necessary.
So what that means is you don't
have to write some of
these ugly macros
and hand inline.
You can have nice functions in
there, especially if it's in
the same file, it
can get inline.
Of course, if you define it to
different file, and this file
doesn't have access
to it, it won't.
But if it is the same file,
it'll get inline, so you get
the same result.
So you can still have this
nice [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
You don't have to be with
optimizations at that level.
So another thing is we
have this entire--
Question?
AUDIENCE: On the previous slide,
other than looking at
the assembly code, how
do we know when the
compiler based this on?
PROFESSOR: You've got
the assembly code.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Why do you prefer
static converge versus inline?
PROFESSOR: So the reason I did
static is basically, I want to
make sure it's not visible
outside the file, so if you
don't make it static, what'll
happen is everybody else had
the visibility and then you kind
of pollute the space with
a lot of names.
So if you give static,
it's only within you.
If I had inline I can't ask it
to forcefully do that, but
what I'm showing is you don't
even have to say inline.
It'll inline by itself.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
this function to be inline
without actually [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Actually, gprof,
what'll happen is the file
will vanish from gprof,
isn't it?
The function will vanish because
gprof will basically,
if you have a function,
you go look, you
don't see the function.
And it might give, even, a bad
impression that OK, that
function is not important, so
that you had to be careful in
that because when you
look at gprof, you
will see some files.
The inline find some functions,
inline function
won't be there.
Am I right, or is it
doing anything
interesting to the samples?
No.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
vanish and oh, yeah, that
function is not important, but
in fact, it might be really
important, but it got inlined.
So that's one way to, a little
bit, worry about.
Does it make sense?
OK.
So we learned bithacks.
So it was really fun.
We are learning all these
interesting bithacks, but the
interesting thing is, in fact,
GCC compiler also knows a lot
of bithacks, so it's also
a pretty smart compiler.
So if you have something like
this, what do you think the
smd would be?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it actually
did this one.
This is very interesting because
what it did was it
didn't do shift.
It did this load effective
address quad instruction, leaq
instruction.
What it does is multiply these
two, and it's add.
It does nothing in here to add,
and then it can add a
constanant.
So this very complex address
mode that is being used for
completely different purpose.
So this [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
address.
It's doing this multiplied by
this, there's nothing to add,
there's no offset to
add, save it here.
So it's actually doing
this multiply-by.
The nice thing is it doesn't
affect any things like
condition codes and stuff
like that, so this is a
fast thing to do.
OK?
Actually, that's interesting.
How would [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
43?
That makes it a little
bit more complicated.
What do you think?
How to multiply something
by 43?
Anybody want to take a guess
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
multiply 43 [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
mul43?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
multiple by 32, have that
multiplied by--
PROFESSOR: So it did something
interesting.
So here's what it did.
I want you guys to stare at it
a little bit and see if you
can even figure out what's going
on here because this is
kind of funky.
So what happens after
the first leaq?
What's an rax?
What's an rax after first
leaq instruction?
Anyone take a wild guess?
AUDIENCE: Five?
PROFESSOR: Five.
Yes, exactly.
What it does is it's
4a+a because this
is a+a, 5a in here.
And then after here,
what happened?
4 times this one
plus this one.
Yeah, it's 21 because 4 times
this is 20, and you add the
whole original rax
21 here, 21.
And then you do this time
again 42, and add
another one, 43.
So it did all this
interesting three
instructions to get to 43.
And so this is fun.
You can spend days giving
different meaning to this and
see what the compiler
generates.
And I notice at some point
say, when do it give up?
And it doesn't give
up for a while.
It start creating some
crazy things.
OK, try one more thing.
OK, this has to be hard.
255.
How did it get 254?
There's no easy way
to do that.
How did that to that?
This is the very interesting
thing in here, so I will show
you this one.
So here is that instructions
you generated.
So what it did was, it's doing
here, getting it 2a, by doing
leaq because since it didn't
give a multiply, it just
multiplied by 1, so it's
just adding these two.
You get 2a.
And then it multiplied by 128 by
doing a bitshift here, and
then it got such a
wonderful thing.
Why did it do this instead of
doing one instruction to 256?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, then it went
and subtracted a 2a
again, and got 254.
So it went overshoot, subtract,
and subject one
more, so [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
got calculated here.
It does a really smart way, I
don't know what complex logic
is there, to basically figure
out these combinations of
instructions that can
do multiplication.
We planned on a bunch of things
until we run into a
couple of thousand.
It was doing these
weird patterns
after a couple of thousand.
Especially if it is to close
to 2 to the power,
it easily find it.
Even primes, it managed
to find.
Actually, before we gave a
prime, and it found it because
it found the closest thing,
and a couple of things
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], and you
can get to the prime.
So it's kind of interesting
how find goes in just
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] multiplies.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So this is a very
interesting question.
So what it's doing is, it has
realized somehow that doing a
direct multiply by 254 is going
to be slower, so the
multiply instruction--
if you go, I think you can
also look at multiply
instruction, how many cycles
it's going to take to come--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Oh, because it needs
to get this 2a again.
So it's [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
use the two 2a.
So by calculating that,
it kept it.
I don't know, you might be
right, because if it
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
2a to 6n2, then there's no
dependency, and right now,
there's a dependent
change here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Twice, yes,
something like that.
Or calculate this separately.
2*8 and 256, and then add
and subtract them.
Might be interesting.
So there are other ways of
doing that, so in fact--
I don't know why, it might be
in because [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
I don't know why they
didn't do that.
But it's thinking.
It's thinking, look at all
instructions, sequence, how
long it would take, and it find
this interesting sequence.
So sometimes when you are
looking into optimized code,
they will look like something
crazy that you can't read
because it does things
like this.
So you found a simple multiply
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], and end up
with a piece of code
like this.
And so you need to kind of
decipher, seeing what's going
on backward.
So that's why reading assembly
is sometimes hard, especially
optimized assembly.
OK, so I did absolute value, and
look, it did the bithack
we basically learned in class.
You can go look at that.
This is the entire thing that
Charles talked about to find
absolute value.
It knew that, so it has attended
Charles' lecture.
That [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
programmer.
OK, so here's interesting
thing.
So what I did was I am doing
update, and I have this big
large array here, and I'm
checking the index to be
within 0 and this value to
before I updated, because I
don't want to write out the
bounds on this setting.
OK?
Makes sense, because I want
to make sure that I
write in the bound.
Interesting thing here is I
am doing two checks, here.
I end up doing only
one check here.
What happened to
my other check?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE], how
big was the array, and
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No, no,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] something a
lot more simpler.
So to give you a hint, this is
unsigned value, and I'm doing
unsigned compare.
What happens if the value
is more than 0?
A signed value that's smaller
than 0 is what
it is like in unsigned.
It's a huge number.
It [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
to be bigger than this one, so
because of that, it can just
say, OK look, I don't
have to check that.
I can unsigned compare, and I
will get anything less than
zero also in there.
So one more thing.
So before I continue with this
one, so if I actually put it
in a loop and say I'm going to
trade [UNINTELLIGIBLE] to this
value in here.
Then what it'll do is, at that
point, it'll inline this.
And when it can complete
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] near the
check, it will know that, in
fact, my bound is going from 0
to this one, so I don't have
to check the bound.
So what this did was this
inlined this function in here
and completely get rid of the
checks completely, and this is
basically the branch condition
in here because
it said, OK, look.
These things are redundant
because I know because I'm
trading from this to this value
within these bounds
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So it is smart in that.
Do you see this, how
this is going?
Cool stuff the compiler does.
So this is why compilers are
smart, when they are smart.
And the interesting thing
is, here's another one.
So now see [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
imagine, because less than
0, I can do that.
How about if I'm checking
from 5,000?
So we generated this
funky code.
It subtracted a 6 here in the
value, and then checked for
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
because it kind of shifted the
value to a 0 basis, basically.
And then you can check that
thing, and then can basically
get two conditions
down to one.
See, the thing is there are many
places where bound checks
is very important.
If you are doing a lot of adding
compilation stuff like
that, if you don't want to
have buffer overflows and
stuff, you want it with
bound checks.
And so optimizing bound checks
is a very important thing.
So having these kind of things
can, in many programs,
probably give good performance,
so that's why
compilers are really good at it
and spend time trying to do
bound checks.
So this is kind of interesting
way of doing that.
So the next thing I want to
look at is vectorization
because all these machines
we have have this as the
instructions, that can run
really fast, and you probably
saw it in there, and see what
kind of code will get produced
after doing something
like that.
So here's a simple program.
So I have two arrays, and I'm
just copying A to B, something
very simple.
And also the other thing to
notice, I know exactly from
where to where I'm copying, and
I also know which arrays
I'm copying, so when
you look at it, it
produces a code like this.
So what it's doing is it's
basically making eax0 here by
doing xorl.
And then basically, moving
the value A into the xmm
registers, much larger.
Instead of having to
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
16 of them, and copying
it back into B.
So basically, you are doing
copying here, an
increment by 16.
By now, every refresh, you're
coping 16 of them.
Why could I just be done
with just putting this
small piece of code?
What additional information this
is taking advantage of?
AUDIENCE: Does it know
that [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Exactly, because it
knows that it goes from 0 to
this value.
In fact, it knows it's
a multiple of 16.
So it knows that.
That's why it do that.
It knows exactly, and these
things are nicely aligned to
the boundaries, word
boundaries.
So it knows that.
So I can read that, and I know
all those facts, and that is
why I can do this computation.
So now, you start doing that,
did one simple change.
You start going from value,
I went to end.
0 to end.
I know where it starts, and
I know where it's ending.
Ending is somewhere at N. I
don't know where the end is.
Then this has to do something
a little bit difficult.
So the code produced looks like
this because, now, I'm
not going to go through
this code.
The only thing to say, this is
actually doing still a memx
instruction, but its trying to
make sure that because N it
might not be a multiple of 16.
You have to take care of the
final number of iterations
outside that, so you had to go
up to the multiple, and then
basically do a normal
loop one at a time.
So as we produce a little
bit of a more
complicated piece like that.
So that's [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
compiler has to do.
And so then you have a piece
of code like this.
The interesting thing here is,
now, I created basically a
function, where it's not A and
B. I'm giving two arrays as
arguments, and then I'm giving
a size to copy, and I'm
copying that.
And I would have an extremely
complicated thing that's
getting generated.
Why is it complicated?
What do I have to know, when I
get this function, to make
sure that, first of all,
it's still doing xmm
somewhere in here.
What that means is it's trying
to do this very fast copy of a
multiple using [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
instruction.
But what else can happen
in this function?
Because compilers delete
all the cases.
What are other cases
tests deal with?
AUDIENCE: May not be aligned.
PROFESSOR: May not be aligned
because, for example, because
xmm assumes that they had
the word boundaries.
When you read 16 bytes, we
assume it's aligned with
16-byte boundary.
It might not be aligned, so you
have no idea where these
two are coming from.
So that's one thing is they
might not be aligned.
What else?
AUDIENCE: They don't even have
to be a [INAUDIBLE].
Because I mean, that thing could
just be copying up to N.
But it might just be copying
partially parts of the array.
PROFESSOR: Yes, yeah,
that's true.
So what that means is because
arrays [UNINTELLIGIBLE] it,
but arrays is somewhere in
memory, just you do two-point
to starting point.
That is what x and y are there,
two starting points in
main memory, and start
copying there.
So what else can happen
because of that?
Because in A and B, we knew they
were two separate arrays.
What else can happen?
Back there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So arrays can start to overlap,
and if arrays are
overlapping, then you
might end up in
an interesting situation.
So you have to figure out if
that arrays are overlapping,
whether they're aligned.
Actually, there are two
types of aligned.
One is self-aligning, so assume
we took these arrays
and start copying
from the byte 3.
So then what you know is
basically byte 3 to 16, it's
not aligned.
You can't start copying
chunks in there.
So you run bytes, but when you
run up to 13 iterations, then
you end up in, again,
aligned chunks.
So in that case, you just run
the sum preamble to first
aligned place, and then you
go to aligned chunk.
But if this is starting to at 3,
this is starting at 8, then
they're never going
to be aligned.
The things are copying A and B
are not aligned, so then you
have to treat it differently.
So there's a lot of different
cases you have to do, so if
you just give something like
this, the problem is the
compiler has to deal with
these thousands
of different cases.
And in this one, since this
small, it probably tore
through all the possible cases
at the [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So it's dealing with all those,
and checking over
everything and trying to find
optimal case and do that fast,
hoping that you get optimal
case for it.
But if you have something more
complicated, the compiler
won't be able to do all
of those things, so
it might give up.
So the interesting thing to here
note is more information
to go into the compiler
is better.
And then here, compiler has to
divide a lot of things, but
probably not happen.
Another interesting thing is
now, the first time I just
copy to where is A to B, in
memcpy4, I just call memcpy3
by doing the same thing, A to B,
copy 1024 [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
This is the beauty
of inlining.
So what it did was, in memcpy4,
it inline memcpy3 and
substitute X and Y to A
and B and end 2,024.
And it realized that it doesn't
have to do all these
tests like it did.
What it generated is very close
to what we got here
because after inlining, it
should realize, wait a minute,
I'm copying A to B. I know
we have the start.
I know we have the end.
I know the size.
I know all of these things, and
I don't have to do any of
these things.
I can actually generate this
very simple piece of code.
So I think that is
a neat thing.
What this shows you is, in fact,
if you can build this
general function of things in
there, and then you can call
them, and if it is done right,
the inlining will basically do
all optimizations.
So you don't have to have 50
different memcpies for all the
different things in your code.
If you wrote a general function,
and you call it in a
way it can get inline and got
that as efficient as possible
as hand optimization.
I think it's a real interesting
thing, and what
does for you, when you're doing
projects, you don't have
to do all of these very complex
and small functions,
hand inline stuff like that.
But it's always good to check
that, in fact, the compiler's
doing that because
you don't know.
You assume the compiler's doing
that, and there might be
cases it might not be.
And I will show you
one example here.
So I want you guys to look at
this function a little bit.
OK?
I am doing two memcpies.
I am copying 1,024 elements.
One, I'm doing ai+1, a into--
this is XY, this is X get copied
into Y. ai+1 to A, so
that means I have array like
that, array like this.
I am giving ai+1
as the source.
I am giving this as the source,
and I'm doing this as
the destination.
OK, what does this copy do?
I'm copying 1,024, yes.
So the first one, this one
gets copied to here.
Second iteration, this
will get copied.
Third iteration, this will
get copied to here.
What does it do?
Yeah, I just do one left-shift
of the array.
My second example.
I give this as my
first element.
This as my source.
This as my destination.
What happens here?
AUDIENCE: All your copies
have the same number.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
All of them will copy
the same number.
OK, so now, if you look at the
code that's been produced, so
the interesting thing here is
it realizes, in this one, I
can still do mmx because I can
still copy, take a chunk, and
copy it one back, take a chunk
and copy it one back, take a
chunk and copy it one back.
OK, do you see that?
But what does the next one do?
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
mmx is, and what does
this one do?
Copying something from dl--
[? movzdl ?]
array expressed dl.
Reverse dl, is this
copied, this one?
I hope I copied it properly.
That doesn't look right to me.
So this is interesting.
So I might have missed
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
I think it takes--
This doesn't look
right, does it?
AUDIENCE: So what's a bound?
It's char, I see.
One byte.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, one byte.
AUDIENCE: So what this is doing
is just taking the first
byte, and then just moving it.
PROFESSOR: Into edx?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, right,
this is actually
doing the right thing.
It's doing the right thing, so
what it does is this move this
one into edx, entire thing, and
then this calls the dl, it
gets the first byte
out of edx.
Do you see what's
happening here?
So a gets into--
first [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
the first byte out in here, and
then you keep copying that
byte one at a time into
this location.
AUDIENCE: So it's not smart
enough to [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So this is where we
find something interesting in
the compiler.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So what doing is, in
here, you are copying this
byte into edx.
So dl is the first
bite out of edl.
That's byte, because what--
AUDIENCE: The first byte.
PROFESSOR: Yes, because except
the six address themes, do you
do r32e, r64e, 32, and just
dl is just first byte
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], but
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
low byte of that.
d is just the higher byte.
AUDIENCE: So why does it just
take the first byte?
PROFESSOR: Because this
byte get copied
into everything here.
So do you see that?
This byte is the one that--
because that's what happened
when this copy is basically
this byte got everything
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
got replaced by this
first byte in here.
And you incorporate in there,
and then it just goes around
copying it in here.
So I try, I did it this way,
so what I did was basically
went from 1 to 1,025.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
0.
This is basically
what happened.
So one 2,025, I got a 0, and
then basically that's what
happens in here, same
thing here.
OK?
Do you see what's going on?
But I just did something else,
so assume [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
is doing right here.
What happens if I just
use something else?
I use B[0], so it should
be the same, isn't it?
If I use b[0]
here, instead of doing A[i],
this should be B[i], isn't it?
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry, where
is [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's a different array.
Sorry, I didn't put it here.
So instead of A[0]
here, I put another
array, B[0], here.
Does it matter whether
that's A[0]
or B[0]?
B[0]
is a different array.
It shouldn't matter because a
different array, different
element that you don't do that,
but the interesting
thing is if you do that,
it managed to
convert it into mmx.
So this is where the compiler
is basically falling short a
little bit because it could have
done this for these two.
OK, it's the same thing because
what it does is it
takes this one element from
me and copy it everywhere.
I could have done it, but for
some reason, the compiler
decided if using a different
array, B[0].
I can do it, but
I'm doing A[0]
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], even though
these two are basically
identical except these
are different.
I'm not doing any kind of
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], anything.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes, so what does
is when it goes somewhere,
it's doing pac.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] pac
instructions in here.
What it does is it takes a
byte and kind of makes
multiple copies of the byte and
create a larger copy than
the 16 copies in there, and then
it can kind of stamp it
everywhere.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
because the A[0] would
go off of A[1].
PROFESSOR: So what it's
doing is copying A[0]
multiple times one at
a times slowly.
So what this does is it takes
B[0], make 16 copies in there,
in registers, not in memory.
I created a template of
16, and I kind of
stamp it as I go.
AUDIENCE: That's probably
failure of its alias analysis.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's failure
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So this is where the compiler
does some magic, kind of very
complex things in here.
But somewhere in the
compiler it failed.
so what you want in here is a
code looking like this, but it
produces this one.
So this is where the compilers
are great.
It do some amazing things,
but it's not infallible.
It can do, there might be
corner cases that data
analysis fails.
So that's why it's always good,
even though you can take
advantage of the compiler, to
look at what's generating.
And sometimes when you tweak
around it, you suddenly
realize, wait a minute.
I can get the compiler do
something better, and then you
can say wait a minute, now how
do I work myself back?
Sometimes, you end up changing
your SQL a little bit like the
examples, the TAs showed when
they were doing their demo,
that if you tweak it a little,
you can actually get the
compiler to do that, instead
of trying to do
these things by hand.
So the compilers are powerful,
but you have to be careful.
Another interesting thing
is this factorial here.
So normal factorial is basically
you call a function
call with x-1 and
multiply by x.
But you know functions calls
are very expensive, and in
fact, GCC knows that, too.
So what GCC did, it basically
eliminated the function call
and converted it into
its [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
function here.
So if EDA got x in here, and
then it goes to a loop, so it
first check with
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
If it is one, you go to
the end and return it.
You are done if x is
1 or less than 1.
And otherwise, it goes
through a loop.
It doesn't go do any
function call.
It just basically calculate this
fact value inside EAX and
keep multiplying
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So it can take this simple
recursive functions, and also
convert it into
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So it does some very, very fancy
stuff in the compiler.
So the compilers are
fun when they work.
But the key thing is there are
many cases it doesn't work.
So next, I want to
switch gears.
Any questions so far?
Sometimes it's fun
to find breaking
points in the compiler.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: If I use, in some--
this is not static?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: No, it won't make a
difference because what it
says is if it is not static,
it's visible to the outside
world, but within this function,
it's the same.
So what it does, it kind of
like limiting my pollution
because otherwise what happens
is everybody outside will see
these names.
So if you use that name again
somewhere, it might
just use this one.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
this is within the file, nobody
else should see this.
It's creating a local copy.
It's kind of a poor man's
class heierarchy.
In Java, basically, each file
is a single class, and you
make sure that things
inside the class is
not visible to outside.
When you make static, you made
it only visible within that
file, so you kind of make
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
You can think about your file
as your class, and so you
limit the scope of the
variable doing that.
So some benefits of
object-orientedness can be
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], I guess.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] static
variable,
it's not a class variable.
OK, so next, before I get into
doing compilers and say what
compilers do, I want to give
you a [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
There are many different
places where you can do
optimization.
So if you look at what happens
in the program, program first
goes through compile time,
compiles each file, then it
links all the files together.
At some point, the files will
get loaded into your machine,
and then it'll be running.
So if you load things in a
compiler, you have full access
to source code, it's very easy
to kind of look at the
high-level transformation,
low-level transformation, you
can look at the entire gamut
of things to do.
And the nice thing
about compilers,
compilers can be slow.
Nobody's going to complain.
It's not going to be part of
your run-time, so you just
would wait, but it's you,
not the customer.
But the problem with compilers,
it doesn't see the
whole programs.
You see a file at a time, so
all this inline things and
stuff has to be in the file.
You can't put in a different
file and get [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
And also don't know the run-time
conditions because
that's run-time.
It might be having different
inputs, different size of load
and stuff, that I don't know
any of those things.
And also, I don't know about
the architecture, so if my
compiler have to make sure that
it works on AMD machines,
Intel machines, stuff like that,
of course, you can use
special flags and try to comply
for one machine, and
breaks, you finish
on the other one.
But you don't want to do that,
so the compiler has to be a
lot more general, and this can
be sometimes problematic.
So when you're going to link,
the nice thing is that this is
a place you have the entire
program available.
Sometimes, people try to do
things like inlining in the
linktime, because that means you
know everything in there,
so you went with couple
different file I can inline it
because I have access
through here.
And still, there might be things
that's not available,
like dynamically-loaded classes
and dynamic-loaded
data, and so things like Java
might not be available.
And of course, you don't
have access to
source most of the time.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, sir.
What do you mean [INAUDIBLE]?
Do you have the full program
[INAUDIBLE]?
But so how do you say
that [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So dynamic links,
if you have something like
Java, there might be some data
that kind of get dynamically
generated or dynamically
linked.
So when you're running, if
you're running right
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] your browser,
all those Javascript classes
and stuff like that, you don't
have access to because those
are coming in here.
So there might be places,
things that
it gets as it runs.
Not in C, but in other
languages.
And the load is interesting
time.
Here, load time is important
because when you double-click,
you want your program
to appear fast.
You don't want it to
take a long time.
But you have kind of access to
all that code in here, and you
have some idea about the
run-time, also, the
architecture, and stuff like
that, what you have, not the
run-time, but the architecture,
exactly what
machines you are running.
And then, of course, you
can do it run-time.
The thing about run-time is
you have full knowledge of
everything, it's great, but
every clock cycle you spend
optimizing is one clock
cycle you take
away from the program.
So things like Java JIT
compilers, they try to do
minimal things, so
very fast things.
It can't do a lot of complicated
things because
it's too expensive.
OK, so we're not talking about
any of these things any more,
but it's always good to know,
as you go about using Python
or Java or JavaScript and stuff
like this where is this
thing happening to my code?
Because it might not be all
compile-time stuff.
It might be happening
at different stages.
So you need to know who's
actually mucking with your
code, and know that there
are other people who can
muck with your code.
So next, I want to switch
into dataflow analysis.
So this is what compilers are
good at, and compilers try to
do all the time.
So it's basically compile-time
reasoning about run-time
values and variables, or
expressions, within the
program at different
program points.
OK, so that means compile-time,
I need to know I
have this program point,
what could it be.
So things like which assignment
statement produced
a value or variable
that I am using?
OK, if I use a value, who
actually created that value?
Or which variable contain values
that are no longer
being used by somebody here?
So that means I am trying to
analyze the program and watch
the range of values that
each variable can have.
So the key thing here is this
has to be true for every
possible input at every
possible execution.
Normally, [UNINTELLIGIBLE], and
this time, I know why my
variable [UNINTELLIGIBLE], but
every possible time, this has
to be true.
OK, if there's a condition that
something can happen, you
have to make sure that condition
is not going to
break your program.
Last thing you want from
optimizer is to basically
start producing different
results.
Even [UNINTELLIGIBLE], it's
not good, so you want a
compile optimizer to kind of
produce the same result that
you got without optimizing.
And this is why this has
to be [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So first, I want to go through
a little bit of example, what
kind of things the
compiler do.
You probably have seen this in
one of the earlier lectures.
We talked about some of this as
hand optimizations, but I'm
going to go through some of them
by using this program.
It doesn't mean anything
what I'm doing here.
I have a loop here.
I'm calculating some
function in here.
And then I am adding something
else to this x here, and I
have some initializations in
here, just something that I
can demonstrate what it does.
So it has no meaning
for this one.
And here's the assembly
instructions.
I'm not going to go through
assembly, but [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
you can actually create and
understand why this is
happening in [INAUDIBLE].
So I [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
into two slides.
The first thing you can do is
think of constant propagation.
So what it says is for all
possible executions, if a
value that has in a variable is
the same, and we know that
value, that's a constant.
And I don't have to keep that
value in that variable.
I can replace that
with a constant.
Sometimes, when you look at
dataflow optimization, you can
say this is done.
As a programmer, I will
never do that.
This is something you should
be doing, for example, have
things like constant variables
that constant values or lower.
But sometimes, something looks
dumb, but what happens is
sometimes when you're in
optimization does, one
optimization might lead to
code that looks like.
That can lead to it.
I will show you something
sometimes that you might not
find a code that looks dumb, but
previous optimization will
leave, or change the code in a
way that this optimization can
take advantage of.
So nice thing about this is you
don't need to keep values
in the variables because you can
free some variable, that
means free RAM registers.
Also, most of the time when you
do constant propagation it
leads to [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
optimizations.
So in this program what are
the things that can be
constant propagated?
So we know x equals 0, x's are
constant up to this point.
But since x get modified here,
my dataflow say wait a minute,
I am going through this loop,
and x is constant
from here to here.
But after this point, x is not
constant because it get
modified in here.
So that's what dataflow is
going to say, and so I
can't do that x.
But [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
why it become constant here?
All input that goes into this
loop, has to go through here,
becomes constant
in every path.
And then it doesn't get modified
in this loop at all.
OK, so then I can actually,
through constant propagation,
get to the file.
OK, so now I have a
program like that.
So normal compiler optimization
is done by
pass-by-pass.
A lot of passes get repeated
multiple times, so I
leave it like this.
So even though this is just
simple thing, but we leave it
to somebody else to optimize
that, which is what we call
algebraic simplification.
Basically, it says you go to
your, whatever, fourth grade,
fifth grade, sixth grade
algebra book--
I don't know where you learn,
somewhere you learned
algebraic --and they have all
these very simple rules, like
something multiplied by 0 is 0,
multiply 1 by that, and all
of those rules, and then you can
just busy code them up and
look for these patterns
and replace.
And that's what the
compiler does.
And in fact, we look at
something like this, a simple
shape, but you saw before
that, it do much more
complicated things.
And it's a lot less work at
run-time, and also it leads to
more optimization, so it can
simplify things in here.
And other thing is, sometimes
instead of algebraic
simplification, kind
of weird things.
If you want exact precise, for
example if you're doing
floating point, because floating
point, a plus b plus
c, is not b plus c plus a, are
different because you can get
small teeny differences
in these kind of--
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
and associate duty, and
some people care.
Most people don't because it's
so small, most people, they
don't care.
Others do.
And also sometimes when you do
this optimization, things like
overflow and underflow, that
happens because if I do x plus
x minus x, or x is very large,
x plus x minus overflow, and
then you end of doing minus
x because it overflows.
But instead of x plus x minus
x, it's just x, you don't
overflow anymore.
So you have changed the behavior
of the program, but
most of the time, compilers
think that things like that
are special cases.
They are not the normal
behavior, so changing them is
probably OK.
Sometimes, you can't
do anything.
So now here, what are algebraic
simplification I can do?
What can I do here?
Yeah, I multiply by 0,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
this, that.
At 0, I leave it here, and then
there's another algebraic
simplification, I can do that,
but now, I am leaving it here
because there's no algebraic
simplification.
X equals x is--
there's nothing you can do.
That's called copy
propagation.
Copy propagation says you're
just making a copy of one
value to another, just
get another copy.
You don't need to do a copy.
Very simple thing in here.
Less instructions, less
memory registers
because we are not copying.
However, when we
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
register location, I will
talk, basically.
If I use the same register now,
I might have things that
was in two registers, x copied
to y, now it's all in x.
So that means I might have some
variable in the register
that you call my interference
graph.
I'll talk about this in a little
while, so I'm just
forward referencing.
That might not be easily
register locatable.
And so in here, x equals x.
I can get rid of that.
And another interesting thing
is common subexpression
elimination.
If you do the same thing
multiple times, you calculate
it once, less computation, Cons
is you need to keep this
result somewhere between
the two users.
So if I have too many of these
things, I might just run out
of registers to keep these
values calculated.
And also interesting thing is,
this can hinder things like
parallelization.
When we get there, we can see
that by adding additional
dependencies in there.
So in here, what are the
common expressions?
Either you guys are bored, or
this slide is way too hard.
You're bored?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: y plus 1, OK, good.
So there's y plus 1 in here, and
I can calculate it once,
and then I can just do the
multiplication of that, and do
that, and voila.
It got rid of two addition and
one multiplication to one
addition and one
multiplication.
OK, next thing is dead
code elimination.
So if you're doing something
that nobody's using the value,
why do you do it?
And less computation, and maybe
you release storage
because you're not storing these
values your computing,
and that's really nice.
And there's not much of bad
things about dead code.
Dead code is pretty dead.
You can get rid of it.
So here, what are the
dead code you have?
I want keep you at least
somewhat engaged, so see if
you can find my dead code.
AUDIENCE: y.
PROFESSOR: y, yeah.
I got rid of [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Now, I don't need it, I can just
get rid of that, and then
I can even get rid
of allocating y.
So I got rid of both instruction
and some
memory-allocated registry that
used to keep that value there.
Another interesting thing you
can do is loop invariant code
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] because loops
are very important.
Most of execution time is mainly
inside loops, so if you
can get something out of a
loop, that's really good.
We talked about that
previously.
But you have to worry about,
basically, two things.
One thing is that when you move
too many things out of
the loops, you have to keep all
those values in registers,
so that means you need more
registers inside the loop.
Second thing is when you execute
that, you have to make
sure that it have the
same behavior as
when you run the program.
How about special cases, the
loop never get executed.
First let's look at this.
What other loop invariant
expressions in here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Hm?
AUDIENCE: 4 times
[INAUDIBLE]--
PROFESSOR: 4 times eta
a divided by b.
OK, good, I just
moved up there.
So I did that, but why
am I really wrong?
Why won't the compiler
do this?
Give me a case that this would
change the program behavior.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: 4 times overflow,
yeah, that can happen.
That's one case, but there's
something that can happen--
overflow happens in very large
numbers, people don't care
that much, but there's
something that can
happen a lot more.
AUDIENCE: If B is 0, and
then N is less than 0?
PROFESSOR: Exactly, when B[0]
and N is less than 0.
I am going to have a divide by
0 error in here because I am
going here, dividing by 0.
That would have never happened
because the loop wouldn't have
gone and executed it.
So normally, when you do things
like that in a loop,
the compiler generate a place
called a landing pad, which
basically is, before you enter
the loop, you check whether
the loop will ever
get executed.
And then go to the landing pad,
and then go to the loop.
So the landing pad will be run
only when the loop at least
has one iteration running, and
so you can move all those
thing in the landing pad.
So here, you can see there's
no landing pad.
The code generated probably
would have, and so I did
something that is, you would
see in fact, the optimized
code I did didn't do that.
So GCC minus [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
is smart
enough not to do this.
So then there's another type of
strength reduction, which
is saying if I go something like
a times i, what I can do
is just, instead of doing a
times i, I can basically make
the first iteration initialize
it, and every time you can
update the previous value.
OK, so array times i, the first
it's 0 and next time
it'll be t plus 80 plus this,
so I can keep updating that.
OK, so this is really good.
I have this computation because
now we just sort of
multiply, I just made it add.
But I have a lot of problems
that can happen here.
First of all, I have,
now, this one.
I didn't have to keep this
value anywhere, only
when I needed it.
In here, this value has to be
varied through out the entire
loop because I keep updating
that value, so I created
another need for a register.
Before now, I only needed
it at that point.
I could've [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
rarely used it, but now it
just to be there throughout
the program
I created in there.
Also what I fear is what they
call a loop-carried
dependence.
Every time you run iteration,
you use the previous
iteration's value.
When we go into a parallelizing
loop, you
suddenly realize that means I
can't run them parallel, so
this creates a huge problem
in parallelization.
So you do [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
strength increase, when you go
to parallelize.
And you can undo these things.
So in here, one thing you can
do is you look at something
like u times i and say wait
a minute, I don't have to
multiply by i because
it [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
0 like this, and I can just
allocate a value b and keep it
updating by v, and then I did
that, allocated a variable in
here, allocated 0.
And [UNINTELLIGIBLE] this, I
just basically put v times 0.
You see that?
I just basically got rid of a
multiplication and convert it
into addition, but I paid some
cost by, I need now this
additional register
that is true all
throughout the entire thing.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
I just calculated
that expression.
And the big thing a lot you
get performances register
allocation, so most processes
have very few registers.
In fact, one big change that
when you went from
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
is to get additional
registers.
Registers are very important.
I will go through register
location a little bit.
So what happens is when you
have a program, you have a
control goes like this.
So this control going, executing
something that
defines this variable x,
defines variable y.
And here, you use variable x and
variable y, and there are
different paths the program
can go through.
There are two paths can merge
in here, here, you
can expand in here.
So this is kind of the flow of
the program in a small part.
So what you can say is this
definition [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
here, so this value, this
line in between here--
because you can't
get rid of it.
When you decided you had to
keep it somewhere because
somebody's going to
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
And this definition is used
here, so when you decided you
had to be [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
in here.
When you [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
is only used here.
Nobody uses here, so this has
to be [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Interesting thing about x is
there are two definitions of x
that might be used here, and
this definition might be used
here or here.
So you put all this into what
they call a one web because
these two definitions might--
either one of them will
be used here.
This definition will be used,
either one, over here, so this
value has to be [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
in here, kept somewhere.
So then what we say is we
give names to these,
so this is s1, s2.
Somebody has to keep
this value.
s2 keeps this value, s3
keeps this value,
s4 keeps this value.
The interesting thing is how
many registers you need to
keep all those values.
That's why the entire thing
of register allocation.
So what you do is this really
cute mapping of this into nice
theoretical problem.
So what you can say is each of
these regions, we make it
vertex of a graph.
If these regions overlap,
then we get edge.
S1 and s2 overlap.
That means you can't use the
same register to keep s1 one
and s2 because before s1 is
finished using, s2 has to be
free of that.
OK, there's overlap in here, so
we've created edge in here.
OK, s2 and s3.
So s2 and s3 overlaps here
because at this point, both
value s2 and s3 has
to be kept.
So I create an edge in here.
OK, so I create an edge.
Every time I say
those do values
need separate registers.
I can't keep the
same register.
And of course, s3 and s4.
s3 is here.
s4 can be in the
same register.
So there's no edge here.
os1 and s4 can be in
the same register.
os2 and s4 can be in the same
register because they are not
live at the same time.
They are live at a different
time of the program execution.
Now, what you can do is, you
have a graph, you have edges,
and there's this very famous
problem called
graph coloring problem.
How many heard of graph
coloring problem?
OK, good.
So what happens is now we can
figure out how many colors
need to color this graph, and
that is the number of colors
of the number of registers
you need.
So if you have a graph like this
with no edges, you can
color it with one color.
How many colors for this one?
Two colors.
People said two colors.
Yes, you can color it
with two colors.
How many colors for this one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's three-color
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So there's all these algorithms
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
and say no.
You can see by coloring this
how many registers I need.
And the interesting is, if you
need more colors than the
register you have, that means
you can't register allocate,
and at that point, you need
too many things to keep.
You don't have that many
registers and that
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
That means you take edge and
say, ah-hah, I can't keep both
of these guys in the same.
I will take some vertex out and
say this vertex can't be
in there because I can't put
it into register, and
I spill this out.
And you can re-color
the graphs.
You can spill it, and of course,
spilling is costly
because now [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
value in the register, it's in
the memory, so every time you
need it, you had to bring it
back, send it back, so it's
going to be expensive.
The nice thing is to
see how much you
can keep in the register.
So I have enough registers for
this program, so I found
registers for all these
things instead of
putting it in memory.
And now, this is
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
register allocation in a pseudo
C code, so this is the
kind of optimized code, and
this is the generated--
Basically, all four of the
original program generated.
But in here, I move
this one up.
But in this one, actually, the
division didn't get moved up,
so [UNINTELLIGIBLE] actually
inside the loop because it's
realized you can't do that.
But interestingly moved the
multiplication out, so that it
didn't care about
the overflow.
It says, hey, overflow, it can
have an overflow, but it will
worry more about divide by 0.
OK?
Any questions so far?
So here's the optimized code,
and if you run it, there's
seconds versus 54 seconds.
Just GCC [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
0, GCC os, so it'll produce very
compact optimized code.
So the key thing is what's
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] these
optimizations.
The key thing is you have to
guarantee, when you optimize,
all that these programs
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
from unoptimized, optimized, all
the valid input, all the
valid execution, and all valid
architecture that you're
supposed to run, you can't
do the same thing.
Otherwise, it's not a good
optimizer if it does different
things to code.
So there are a lot of things
that means you have to be very
conservative in [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
cases.
So you have to understand both
control-flow and data
accesses, and make sure that
you understand them, and if
any of them, the compile-time
analysis cannot understand,
the compiler give
up very fast.
So the thing is, most of the
time if that information is
not available, compilers reduce
the scope of the region
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
the transformation.
So we have this point, I
don't know beyond that.
I can only do a small amount
of transformations here.
Or reduce the aggressiveness
of transformations, and
sometimes just completely leave
code alone as it is
because it couldn't, even the
things you know, no sane
program would do, and
of course, your
code will never do.
The compiler assume,
if it is a valid C
semantics, it might happen.
Even though some of them
looked really crazy.
If it is a valid possible way
of doing it, compiler has to
worry about it, and
not do that.
So it's here to be
careful of that.
So first of all, control-flow.
That means it doesn't work on
possible paths of the program
when you execute that.
And the way you look at this,
you can add this call graphs
in the high-level
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] the call in
here, and control-flow graphs
within the metadata function
how control goes from.
And what makes it hard for
compiler to analysis this?
Bunch of things [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
function pointers.
You probably haven't done
function pointers, but if you
have function pointers in the
compiler concepts, I don't
know where it's going.
I have to be very careful.
Indirect branches.
so I keep addresses somewhere
in that branch, so that I
don't know where it's going.
Something computed go
to [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Large switch statement.
It's just spaghetti code.
We have no idea where it would
end up and compile at us, and
we can't get anywhere in
this switch statement.
Either [UNINTELLIGIBLE] you
might know some order of going
through that, it doesn't work.
If you are looped with
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
breaks and very complex things
in the compiler, sometimes
it'll give up.
When the loop bounds are
unknown, you'd assume it could
be anything.
Whereas when loop bounds are
known, as you saw in the first
set of examples, you can take
advantages a lot more, and you
can do a lot more aggressive
things, or not care about
cases because I know that.
But in this unknown loop bounds,
you have to be a lot
more careful of that.
And conditions where branch
is not analyzable.
So if you have branch condition,
if you don't know
what's happening in the branch,
I might not be able to
take advantages or think how
to do the branch well.
So those are the things that
I have to worry about.
The other thing is data
accessors, so that means who
else can read and
write the data.
So I am touching the data item,
and I need to know that,
between the two points I am
looking at the data, nobody
else go and muck with my
data, or use my data.
Because when I look at the
data, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
something, I want to make sure
that's the only way that data
can be accessed because, as you
know, most of the things
are in memory.
So normally compiler
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] is called
def-use chains, so defined to
use, so we say that thing that
defined here is going to get
used here, and nothing comes
in between that.
And that information is that's
how the compiler
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
That's something we call
dependence vectors.
We might talk a little bit about
that when you go into
parallel execution.
So what makes it very hard for
compiler to analyze this?
For example, address taken
variables, so if you write and
hack with C, you can say,
OK, there's a variable.
There's a variable here, I'm
taking the address of that.
Suddenly, that means somebody
else has the
address to the variable.
That means anybody else can
suddenly jump in and overwrite
you, and there's a lot of
possibilities of doing that.
And suddenly compiler says wait
a minute, that variable,
even though I assigned the
variable here, I'm using it
here, in between.
Somebody else might touch it
even though it might not use
the same name because somebody
has that address to that.
OK, so that's a hard thing.
Global variables, sometimes,
because between function, I
don't know.
Some other function might
go and change it.
Parameters are really hard.
Like for example, remember when
we had a program, and we
had something like copying same
array to the same, even
though parameters say X and Y.
I might send the same or
overlapping regions into two
different parameters even
though it looks like two
different names.
They're not two different
things.
They're actually overlapping
at some point.
And so you had to assume, even
if you have two different
parameters point into memory,
they might be the same thing.
And that's the worst case, even
though a lot of times,
nobody does that.
Nobody gives the same
things multiple
names, but it's possible.
If it is possible, compilers
deal with it.
Either it has to generate code
to test all these cases, is it
overlapping, if not,
do something.
If it is overlapping, do
something slower, like the
code we showed when you
are vectorizing.
You treat it like this huge
number of different cases, but
unless you do something like
that, you can't optimize, and
complex programs, it's
very hard to do that.
A lot of times, pointers create
issues in here because
the problem with pointers is
what you call it point
aliasing, because pointers,
you can add any value to a
pointer and you have no idea if
you had a very large value.
It can be anywhere in memory
because if you have a pointer,
you have a point in the
memory you can add
anything, subtract anything.
The world is yours, and C gives
you this ability to go
all over the world and kind of
mapping the world, and some
programs do that.
And so the compiler says,
oh, it's a point.
I don't know where it is.
I just have to leave it alone
because some guy, probably
0.001% of the world programmers
will do something
crazy, and everybody has
to pay the price.
So this is what makes
programming hard.
And the final thing is there's
a thing called
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] types.
When you go to parallel
programming you realize,
because normally compilers
keep normal
values are in the memory.
Compiler can [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
the value into register and
keep operating in the register,
and at some point,
put it back to memory.
But if you're running a parallel
program, somebody
else might want to look at that
value, and if it isn't
registered, you don't have that
value in the right place.
It's somewhere else, so you get
a stale copy because you
have moved it.
What I'm trying to say is, look,
you have to always keep
it in memory.
You can't take it out.
You can't just modify it, but
you can move it somewhere else
the faster place to do things
to it because somebody else
might be looking at it.
And so what that means is
compilers give up it's hands
and say, look, I can't
do anything.
So we are a little bit early.
I have yet another huge
session in here at--
OK, we have to go through
this thing.
Good.
I think now we are going to go
about and see how you guys did
in the class exam.
OK.
And I'm seeing it for the
first time, and it looks
really nice.
Where do you plug this in?
OK, so here is the distribution
in there.
This was not an easy exam, and
in fact, we compared how you
guys did last year, and you guys
have done a lot better
than I think the first
exam in last year.
So basically, we have a median
about 70, somewhere here, and
a nice tight grouping in here,
which is really good.
And so what we have is,
we have exams back.
Take a look.
And I think--
GUEST SPEAKER: I'd like to
make one comment about
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, sure.
GUEST SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
So not surprisingly, I graded
the problem on the cache
oblivious algorithm doing
the recursion tree.
There is a common mistake that
many people made, which I
wanted to explain why it's wrong
because so many people
made this mistake.
They got it almost all
right, and then
they made this mistake.
So it's basically an
understanding of recurrence.
So the recurrences I recall was
q of r is equal to square
root of r over b if square root
of r is less than CM for
C, et cetera.
OK?
And then otherwise, it was 2q
of r over 2 plus theta 1.
Now, what people did in
their recursion tree--
first of all, some people didn't
recognize that what
goes in the recursion tree is
this value, the number of
cache misses.
So the recursion tree is going
to look like theta 1, or you
can leave out the thetas
if you want to put
them in at the end.
Theta 1, theta 1, et cetera.
So many people got this, and
then the question is what
happens when it hits the leaf.
OK?
So when it hits a leaf, many
people correctly got that you
can't mess around
with constants.
You have to be very careful of
constants if they're in an
exponent, that you hit the leaf
when square root of r
becomes less than c over m, in
which case the cost is going
to be square root of r over b.
So what they did was the
incorrect thing, was they put
square root of r over b here.
Why is that wrong?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
GUEST SPEAKER: It's
the wrong r.
Right?
OK, it's the wrong r.
This r is the r here on
the right-hand side.
It's not the one here.
It's the r if r is sufficiently
small, that's the
value you're taking.
But we're expanding an
r from the top here.
So what's the value that
should go here?
OK, cm is the value that
should go here.
OK?
The value that should
go here is cm.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
two r's can actually follow
the right-side?
And then it's very close to
where they're written the same
but are spoken differently.
GUEST SPEAKER: Well, when you
say-- what do you mean?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GUEST SPEAKER: There's
an r here.
AUDIENCE: And it's different
from the other r--
GUEST SPEAKER: No,
it's the same r.
The question is there,
r is a variable.
So it'd be nice if the r were
constant, but it's not.
It's a variable.
And so the point is the point
where you plug it in here,
you've got to plug in, not the
variable, you've got to plug
in the value.
AUDIENCE: You just said for
r [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
GUEST SPEAKER: It's
a variable.
You have to plug in the value of
the variable at this point
if you're going to solve
the recurrence.
Putting an r here, we're trying
to I say, this whole
thing is q of r.
And we started out, if we did
the development of the tree,
which is the safest thing to do,
you get theta 1 plus q of
r over 2, and you keep going
down until your value for r
satisfies this condition.
At that point, what's
the value for r?
OK?
You can't then say it's the same
r that you started with.
It's not this r, and that's
because r is a variable, not
because of anything else.
r is a variable, and
we're using the r.
This is a question of
understanding of the
recurrence.
So in any case, that
was a common
mistake that people make.
The other minor error that
people made on that problem,
that most people made, was in
describing where do you get
this recurrence, they left out
the fact is why is it going to
be square root of r over b.
It's really because na is
approximately nb because the
way that the code works, we're
keeping na and nb to within a
factor of two of each other.
OK?
And so if you didn't mention
that, you lost a point.
It wasn't a big deal, but many
people didn't neglect that
very important statement.
Overall, people did very
well on this problem.
Overall, you'll see people got a
lot of partial credit on it.